he tried to be a photographer one time
how's that going just with language oh
yeah but he thought that you you're like
the photographer's very suggestive
instead of just sort of saying nice
things about what you're doing he
thought it was more of creepy because in
those late nights cinematic movies
that's they portray that's not how it
works I mean it can work if it's done
properly but it's not like creepy you
wanna shoot so it's like you expect the
photographer to be like oh yeah that's
hot do that again you know that kinda
stuff
that's gotta be the greatest job ever
okay give me the dialogue if I'm a male
model okay and you're the photographer
it's the same for both I think it goes
both ways okay so how would it sound
like oh yeah that's super yeah give me
those eyes again that's hot super hot a
little bit yeah Anglet yeah perfect
super sexy again yeah yeah perfect what
if I don't look good they would tell you
they would yeah they would tell you
either like really nice or very blunt
like that is not what you should be
doing have you ever you want for this is
where you follow up with the pepper Oh
any questions I just try to help you out
a little bit what's that just to
reconfirm what we've heard from others
do you want to tell her it was a Chrissy
Teigen it was it was Brooklyn Decker who
initially told me about it yeah that the
person taking the pictures or someone on
the set if they say pepperoni that means
that there's something like your
pepperoni right there's something
showing there that they think you have a
code word if the top goes down is what
the reason why they said pepperoni I
just look at their face they're always
just like and I'm like okay then you
know you have to cover it yeah
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience